more breaking news tonight where you are
following multiple breaking stories
including a bombshell report from the
hill revealing that the FBI is opening a
new investigation into the Clinton
Foundation and also breaking The Daily
Beast reporting the Department of
Justice has taken a fresh look at
Hillary Clinton's private email server
scandal and according to the report DOJ
officials now are interested in finding
out how much classified information was
in fact sent over Clinton's server who
put that information into an
unclassified environment and how they're
also reporting they want to know which
investigators knew about these matters
and when did they know it and in light
of today's a report former senior
adviser to Clinton Philippe Raines wrote
on Twitter quote this is definitely a
political persecution really here with
reaction foxnews contributors tommy
Lehren Jessica at Arlo Happy New Year to
both the youth in here okay now here it
is you have to admit James called me
months before even investigating the
email server scandal is writing the
exoneration now and he had a special
category for Hillary it wasn't done by
the field offices of the FBI now that
they're opening investigations into both
of us can you just admit you can't write
an exoneration before the investigation
no I can't admit that what I can admit
that what happened you can have the
exoneration and then do the
investigation later what several
officials have said that it was normal
practice to begin drafting what you
thought the outcome would be I
completely take your argument but there
are a number of people completely take
my argument I'm dismissing I'm just
saying it's not what I think about it
it's not what a number of people who
have defended James commis decision say
about this either
and then he's doing it with a guy that
calls Trump he's doing it with a guy
that calls Trump loathesome yeah and
loves Hillary but no that guy was a
Kasich supporter and the first excuse me
he wants me
he's on text with his little girlfriend
saying lalala yes she was also on text
with his girlfriend saying I like John
Kasich all right let's bring in time
Larry
Tommy your thoughts I'm just wondering
Jessica when will we hear from Hillary
in all this I mean she seems to like to
talk quite a bit usually in an answer
Trump fashion but we've got all this
coming out about Hillary I'd like to see
herself to the plate Oh anything I come
out about Hillary these are reopening
investigations that have been settled
this is because Jeff Sessions is scared
of Donald Trump because he goes on
Twitter and he says lock her up again he
says my DOJ is supposed to be doing this
this is precious but because you think
that it's important Jeff Sessions was
afraid important that we investigate
this do Democrats do you think it's
important that we investigate matters of
national security do you think that's an
important step to be taken a hundred
percent that's why we did it already I'm
also curious this one questioners use of
private email how do you feel about that
and other White House officials private
email we know in the Clinton case that
secret top secret classified special
access program information it was all
there and that foreign agents it was in
the Comey draft had likely gotten it she
pulled it in a bomb and pop shop
bathroom closet sure looted about the
bathroom the bathroom seems it advisable
though inadvisable
that was a little New York humor you
just don't get my jokes this year no no
anyway everyone knows the server was a
mistake Hillary Clinton knows the server
was a mistake it was a mistake it was a
felony no mishandling of classified
information
destroying classified information is a
felony and when you bleach fit it and
you acid wash it and you bust up the
hammers and you delete it
that's called obstruction Jim Comey just
did this because he wanted Hillary
Clinton only wanted her exactly about
the letter that came out right before
the election that we all agreed I know
judge Peres was certainly they had no
choice at that point there was no choice
but to bring up something that was
completely irrelevant in that it is
Jessica
despite all of this despite all the
people that wanted to see Hillary win
I'm excited because the American people
were too smart for it so I put that a
win in our column yes we're still going
to talk about it because it's a matter
of national security
I want to see Hillary come out and I
want to see her fess up I was with a
dead
you tell me you're gonna see her she's
spoken about this it was a mistake she
has I would love to know what you think
officials using pride old fell into her
diversion Tommy I have another question
all right and it's not even a diversion
it's completely legitimate right to say
here's what I want to know America
doesn't have enough uranium uranium is
the foundational material for nuclear
weapons now why would we ever
why would Hillary Eric Holder why would
knowing Robert Miller knew that Putin
wanted to get a foothold in the uranium
industry in America why and he had his
thugs in this country bribing extorting
money laundering racketeering the whole
bit
and kickbacks why would America why
would anybody ever sign off on giving a
foreign entity control of uranium when
we don't have enough uranium on the
surface does that make any sense to you
at all it doesn't but what I understand
it doesn't it doesn't if that's what
happened but we're sort of transfer
uranium out of the country no sign it
went to Europe and we believe it went to
Asia we believe it we know it went to
Canada if it went to Allies because I
believe Europe and Canada are allies
that's one thing but we have a shortage
Tommy of uranium we need more of it not
less of it this is because we're
resource scarcity actually an Iranian we
are she did sign off on it that's a lot
State Jessica we know it there's so many
there's so many smoking elements here
and the Democrats continue to play it
off well we don't know we don't know you
guys know nothing about this a whole
apparent Russia collusion either but you
still bring it up every sentence we know
that Hillary deleted 33,000 emails we
know about uranium one but yet you're
still going to go back and talk about
Jared Kushner which is a whole lot of
nothing burger because you can't why do
you got to do that but this isn't we
haven't had a thorough investigation and
that you probably want
deleted emails that sure doesn't sound
innocent to me was there 3000
incriminating emails whoopsie the
incriminating emails well she's with
someone as Shawn mentioned why would
someone delete 33,000 emails and bleach
bit a server a private server that they
had in a basement why would they do that
if there was nothing suspect I mean she
says they were her private emails and I
know there's probably more in there
about yoga funeral and a wedding 33000
really you buy that and into email build
emails and she said she also emailed
bill but bill doesn't have an account no
well Bill Clinton personally email that
his staff does the email oh she said
bill well I think she's referring to the
husband doesn't send emails so like she
like she was asked did you did you wipe
the server clean like with a cloth yeah
it's not a funny joke she's not a funny
woman it doesn't mean she's a criminal
walls were broken no it absolutely does
she is still a criminal on the boomerang
but